piers morgan is the host of the upcoming
piers morgan uncensored on fox nation we
know it will be uncensored our friend
we're happy to have him joining us
tonight pierce thanks so much for coming
on so let me just let me just give you
i'm going to let you talk i'm not going
to get in your way let me just say these
are actors
i know a lot of actors they you know
good qualities bad qualities but not a
single authentic public utterance or
action ever because they're actors so
like i don't believe any of this i'm
just saying that
i think it was real and i think because
i think it was real it was actually one
of the most entertaining moments in
oscar's history and then save the oscars
because let's be honest it's normally
this unbearable sycophantic snoozefest
of backs backslappers all telling each
other how wonderful they are i expected
last night to turn into a series of ever
more unctuous virtue signaling speeches
about ukraine but instead we got a
real-life personal war erupt on stage
between two bona fide a superstars and
it was absolutely riveting i was like
half asleep in my hotel room and
somebody was like wow what the hell's
going on here um and at the heart of it
like all wars it began with probably
just a terrible misunderstanding chris
rock from what i gather had no idea that
jada pinkett smith will smith's wife
suffers from this medical condition
called alopecia that caused her to lose
her hair and made her shave all her hair
off last summer had he done that i don't
think he would have done the pretty lame
joke
will smith i think
thought that that chris rock did know
that his wife had the condition and was
deliberately mocking it and at that
moment as he said in his statement
tonight of apology to chris rock and
everybody else he said look i just lost
it in the emotional moment of thinking
this guy was mocking my wife's illness i
can kind of sympathize with both guys uh
but i don't agree with you i don't think
he was a fake i don't think these guys
were acting i think he was the real deal
and that's such a unique moment of
oscar's history
well i'm all for authenticity um i'm
against that kind of authenticity but i
mean i like authentic things of course
but will smith i don't know anything
about this but i read about it today
just done a bunch of interviews talking
about infidelity his his wife's talking
about stuff like no normal person would
ever talk about in public
so he's willing to do that but someone
makes a hair joke and he loses you know
he's funny
i interviewed jada pinkett smith a few
years ago cnn and will smith actually
turned up unexpectedly and he sat in the
corner watching but before the interview
started he came out to me and he said i
didn't know it never met him before he
said mr morgan don't upset my wife you
wouldn't like me when i'm angry and i
thought of that last night because he's
right
nobody would like him when he's that
angry so there's clearly another side to
this guy he's clearly a very emotional
you know possibly at the moment he
looked quite disturbed i don't know
what's going on in his life um but it
certainly came out of nowhere and in a
following before that the oscars last
night was following his normal
unbearable route i thought the absolute
epicenter of woke hypocrisy was watching
one of the hosts uh regina hall who was
actually lusting after male stars on
stage and then began to physically grope
them and all i could think of can you
imagine if a male star had pulled up
four female actresses and began to pour
them on stage that guy would have been
destroyed and cancelled in about five
seconds so there was already a night of
unparalleled hypocrisy uh going down but
in an odd way there was nothing
hypocritical about what we saw with will
smith it was a genuine act of take the
blinkers off this is what i really think
about this guy and i'm gonna go and
smack him one then you know i don't know
there might be guys watching this tucker
tonight i wonder if your own wife was
suffering from a medical condition like
this and have been through a pretty
traumatic time can we hand on heart say
if she was being apparently mocked about
it in front of a billion people would we
not have reacted emotionally and perhaps
in a hot head way i can't guarantee i
wouldn't have done so i give him a
slight pass for that but i do think that
when you look at it in totality
it was an extraordinary moment probably
the most extraordinary moment in the
history of the academy awards and quite
where it leaves everybody in hollywood
with their constant moralizing is only
you and i as to guess
well that is a different way i mean
they've set the bar pretty high there's
going to have to be a murder on stage
next year to keep those numbers up
we're all going to be watching it
i would watch that uh piers morgan on
censors premieres on fox nation
april 25th
we are charter subscribers to this
pierce morgan